we stand here today not at a moment of  tragedy  but in the midst of an enduring tragedy  so far this year guns have taken the  lives of an  estimated eleven thousand of our  neighbors  friends and fellow americans  as the president explained  gun deaths in our country are occurring  at a staggering pace  on the order of about a hundred  americans killed every day  with hundreds more wounded i  am under no illusions about how hard it  is to solve the problem of gun violence  and i know that the department of  justice alone  cannot solve the problem it is a problem  that we must all work on together  in the collective effort to keep guns  out of the hands of criminals  and save lives but there is work for the  department to do  and we intend to do it